[Musik]
also hier haben wir grüne flaschen decke
die haben wir jetzt über die letzten
monate schon gesammelt hatten wir hier
noch auf lager und die werden jetzt
schneller zu kleinen krabbler so
plastikschüsseln die wird ein gleich
weiterverarbeiten
[Musik]
jetzt wollen wir den extruder also
unsere kundschaft melzer mit den
plastischen also den granulat von den
flaschen deckeln der erste preis den
füllen wir dann werden wir vorne statt
dünnen filament so einen dicken strick
studieren und das sind die heizbar
thronen die wir gleich brauchen werden
für unsere spritzgießmaschine
[Musik]
das ist die form die wir gleich das
heiße flüssige plastik rein spritzen
bekommen denn diese halterung aus
unterstützt maschine geladen und die
form ist aufgeheizt druck es aufgebaut
das heißt jetzt werden wir hier den
kolben runter pressen lassen und das
flüssige plastik hier in die vom dritten
gerade nehme ich hier die halterung aus
der vorster medium form raus das ist
gerade die antiken die wir produziert
haben
aus den grünen flaschen decke man sich
hier noch so ein paar fehler also dass
hier müssen wir noch schneiden hier sind
noch so kleine fähnchen
aber sonst ist fertig jetzt machen wir
noch knobloch gummiband rum
dadurch sind die tiere dann einstellbar
und jeder kann das auch seine kopfgröße
einstellen und als labs ist nämlich hier
verstärkte laminiert folie und neben dem
loch der genau richtig eingestellt sein
muss und wochen die folie und die kann
man sagen hier überstülpen so dass die
gäste an dem die vier sitze
und der vorteil ist dass dadurch ist die
folie auch wieder abnehmbar und kann
vielleicht desinfizieren und auch
austauschen
der 3d trend viel zu langsam um eine
hohe stückzahl hergestellt sei die
trasse mehr was zu prototypen und wir
hatten viel zu viele anfragen
die ersten vier wochen alle fertig
bekommen da die entsprechenden jetzt
werden wir machen das mit im
spritzgussverfahren haben die maschinen
gebaut und das erfahren die zu
entwickelt dass wir dieses
schnellverfahren das immer wieder nach
laden und echt schnell hier die
produzieren können und sie möglichst
schnell hier an die organisation an das
rote kreuz bringen kann
[Musik]